order
my terror was old you thought there was
no more torture to confront well you are
wrong okay Jesus what is that - the time
has come to finish what you started
years ago why aren't I used to stuff
like this already Oh God
hello something amiss no security guard
a demon I worked here except a mystery
oh yeah and what mystery is that well
the last time I reviewed a scooby-doo
movie nearly killed me creating a rift
in the space-time continuum from an
angel named Roger that I killed in a
Christmas special years ago links here
ah so there's only one person who could
be responsible for this yes and I have
no idea who that person is seriously but
I know the wild wacky mystery solving
group who can figure it out do they
involve high jinks of course goofy
antics naturally crazy misadventures see
these are all variations of the same
thing but yes and who might they be get
me Gus lassie and Jules what we know
you thought it'd be scooby-doo don't go
we'll show are still doing the reviews
we love this show and the set tires they
do here's one of them and you have to
admit it that we psyched you out in the
end so what do you recommend Jules I
think reviewing the movie will help lead
you to the culprit I think we should get
the hell out of here god I love the
sound of your voice what do you say you
and me do an eight-year cock tease on
par with the office what do you say you
stop doing your aging Zach Braff
impersonation listen Spencer you better
get to doing this review so I can go
back to being a stick-in-the-mud to your
comedic antics lassie please you're
scaring my black sidekick I'm not scared
Shawn will you get over here
excuse me all right I'll review this
movie but only if we have callback to
the 80s that people in their 20s and 30s
would get that doesn't sound familiar
no we try to get the Millennials to
watch Pokemon sucks
you better go with him Gus while I have
hold the status quo all right but I'm
still scared you know I always dance
when I get scared
Wow he went with that dance Hey look um
this really isn't that hard of a mystery
to solve
you know the answer might be right in
front of you wait how did you change
your clothes so fast
well again likes I costume changes are
kind of like blinking around here we
prize stolen more from that show than
the Mentalist if that's possible well if
you're looking for someone to blame for
make you watch this movie just know he's
probably closer than you realize adore
to be in front of her something not that
I bend at home
some people never open their eyes the
film opens with a ray of hope seeing how
it was written by the director of
guardians of the galaxy james gunn but
it's quickly dashed when you see it was
directed by Raja Gosnell which as we all
know is the human incarnation of the
phrase no refunds and yes all the same
actors came back for this okay you have
no excuse you know how bad the first
film was don't you know these movies are
turning out fans like this ah we love
you we have your dad oh Christ more
Buffy fans Hey stop eating that plug
scooby-doo you seem to have fans as well
if you like to see how this movie is
making your kid dumber as he grows up
this movie comes complete with a future
idiot measuring scale so we see your kid
was gonna be a successful district
attorney but after that joke oh he's an
injury lawyer for Chippendale pole
dancers but at least this movie shut him
up for an hour and a half heather
jasper-howe at the grand opening of the
new clues own Ian's criminology Museum
she did it yeah you're literal first
guess is right Alicia Silverstone
playing a pretty reporter a scooby-doo
movie for seemingly no reason at all who
else could it possibly be
no no don't try to cut to a fake-out we
know it's her why else would she act in
this career-ending final nail she's not
even holding the microphone up to the
person she's interviewing I've never
seen someone so desperate to be found
guilty in my life everything okay
any ideas coming to your head I'm fine
Tamara guys come on remember what I told
you never pick your nose in public no
but that's good to repeat is everything
yes
image is everything then why are you
wearing a dress made out of Dino's pubic
hair miss Drake is proud to donate the
costumes of criminals we've unmasked so
the team is opening up an exhibit at the
Museum of all the costumes involved in
the mysteries they solved and give them
some credit they are ones from the
actual cartoon and they look pretty
close what isn't from the cartoon is
Velma having an attraction to a guy okay
now I know you've never seen the cartoon
in your life I think it's pretty obvious
you've been playing for the our teams
and she was a little kid this ends in
both ways let's see what you did this
come out yeah he's gonna trim 2004 when
all comedies were made up of five jokes
yeah you just know how Seth Green got in
this movie hey can I cast all of you in
Robot Chicken only if you'll suffer with
us during scooby-doo - trust me I'm
making a sketch on this so maybe you'd
want to go together like a date with me
no I I can't Patrick ah mystery is my
mistress I must heed her sweet call you
see she didn't say boyfriend she's an
mistress where are the hashtags on this
one but somebody interrupts their
Castlevania exhibit to start trouble
Oh parete i have come to spoil the
turtles coming out of their shell tour
this is only the first rung on the
ladder record - bye
you know this is why you never hire
destro to be a party clown
he matches to bring the pterodactyl to
life and it ends up stealing like
costumes away but it seems Scooby and
Shaggy are blamed for letting him escape
you know Scoob we could act like real
detectives why don't you start by not
having every face you make look like ego
Raptors trying to eat his own shin baby
are you remember we will be awesome
detectives so shaggy decides to solve
the mystery himself oh I mean
shagging a Scooby decide to solve the
mystery themselves sorry it's such a
good effect I had to remind myself how
much he's really there I mean you feel
like you can just reach out and touch
the pixels got the CGI in this is
terrible why can't we go back to
practical effects like when they go into
a flashback showing the original
pterodactyl suit special effects are
dead Jacobo cellmate was released from
prison two months ago the black night
ghost so they go to the opening of their
own credits again always a little mosh
but who cares these little kids have
some killer insults nice job last night
Luthor's that is some stellar kid
writing right there god help you if they
say something complimentary followed by
not quick can you think of a comeback to
what babies want me how to target better
insults in that hey shut up no really
compared to giving thumbs down and
saying loser that is a good one but not
as good as the joke I'm sure you can't
see coming
he just said we'd pay the price shaggy
shaggy shaggy what could possibly happen
by ringing a doorbell I'm lost to the
exploration of possibilities that can
come from this maybe world peace
suddenly breaks out or maybe a cure for
all known diseases is discovered or I
don't know maybe something bad happens
how's that scale for your kid coming by
the way oh look at that he was about to
get into Harvard University now he's
working at a Walmart subway serving cows
not as meat just be happy you didn't
show him a movie with subtitles wafer
guy who spent time in jail he has a
pretty big budget for a mechanical
dungeon I guess working in prison for 69
cents a day went a long way but Daphne
uses her makeup to get them out for
strip a nearly 30 quarter life crisis
surviving girl seriously we should stop
calling the meddling kids and refer to
them as meddling mortgage payers on the
verge of opening a Roth IRA and their
mangy dog probably deceased by now
so while touring through Danny Elfman's
house they come across another monster
costume that's come to life the star of
Astoroth compels you the star of
Astoroth compels you Daphne tries to
fight it off as Velma tries to deduce
where its weaknesses
wait this is 2004 we've already used one
of the five jokes that's used everywhere
but surely the second one must be wrong
tables I hope you didn't want to pass
high school because now he's thinking
paint behind us Sherwin Williams climb
the ladder to get back home to find Seth
green as they're waiting to ask a
nervous Velma out on a date so Daphne
puts her in jinkies H Christ
okay I'm gonna overlook the lesbian
thing so that I can imagine for a moment
that I can actually get that rights
everything so while dressing like a sexy
traffic cone with a head of Sarah Palin
Scooby and Shaggy sneaked out to a bar
where all the old villains they
uncovered hang out now the curious thing
about this idea is it's actually kind of
funny
in fact I dare you even say the writing
for this film is not that bad some of
these jokes are surprisingly kind of
clever
like the stretch mystery van or the fact
that Scooby has a full name normal
shaggy Rogers and scoobert Scooby Doo
even lines like this clearly show
there's some intelligence I have always
found a criminal's inclination to
incorrectly use the interrogative
pronoun in place of the relative
delightfully absurd a2 but here's the
problem the delivery on them is usually
off take this for example
shaggy needs an excuse for why him and
Scooby need to separate so he acts like
scooby has rabies he's got rabies oh
where does go outside to get some fresh
air now that's a funny idea going to an
extreme when a simpler excuse would have
worked fine but the directionless
reactions the bland shot layout even
cutting away too early none of it is
presented right this could have gotten a
laugh but now becomes off as awkward and
confused in fact the film is so
uncertain of where the humor is supposed
to be focused on that they try to
overcompensate with way too many sound
effects that'll mask the fact that we
have no idea what we're doing look at
this scene Scooby and Shaggy are in
disguise and a woman flirts with scooby
he's supposed to flirt back and be funny
but it just comes off as terrifying hey
handsome you know
that alone forget in our rating
you know David that's disgusting oh look
out idiot oh my god I wonder who's
behind that mask oh it's just Peter
Boyle get out of this game why you got a
chance all of us here are a nothing to
admire this is a place for the survivors
of Pluto Nash knit together we are
strong along we are suicidal I see those
twerps I tear their eyes out of their
skulls face everybody makes before they
walk out of this movie you know it is a
Raja Gosnell film should there be a dick
piercingly bad music number right about
now this is exciting ladies and
gentlemen making his first public
appearance the dog-faced hell spawn has
been at everybody's nightmares at some
point you thought he was gone for good
but Raja Gosnell has brought him back to
eat your dreams congratulations your kid
forgot what the number 2 means but
apparently somebody broke into the
museum and stole the rest of the
costumes kinda wish we get to see that
instead of this soggy diarrhea at least
we know Silver's don't didn't do it it's
my job to unmask those who pretend to be
who they're not
soon cools Fair will be mine
oh look he just walked away having no
purpose to that scene whatsoever except
oh I don't know trying to trick us into
thinking she's not the villain my god
how do they write such a good mystery so
pretend you think you can watch this
film without giving credit to the one
who do you teach what happened a ton
whoa somebody cut the Rope up there to
make that drop on you hey guys any
obvious clues around here
hmm I'm getting a feeling there's
something we should notice about our
security guard what is it I'm feeling
that he has rope burns on his hand
appeared just after the accident mmm and
has a nametag that reads Roger well
looks like we figured out who's
responsible for this awful crime Cary
Elwes Tim curry or William Shatner let's
figure out which of these awesome
celebrity guest stars is behind all this
coven we need to do the happy death we
do that peppy dick thank you for helping
us solve this very complex mystery we
need to do the happy dance we do the
happy dick do you need to like a frog to
work here
you
so we see green beating up a guy for
information I guess trying to trick us
again to thinking he might be the
villain clearly not Silverstone because
he walked away it's a perfect you walked
away put on the tough-guy act otherwise
these guys will will they leave me alive
and Seth Green just cranked it's okay
every actor goes through that being on a
scooby-doo movie remember boils cracking
moment just feel lucky he wasn't around
the car speaking of which they follow
boil to an abandoned lab where they come
across a bunch of various formulas look
at those weird letters Scoob raggy oh
Christ it's Winnie the tentacle porn
could things get any more perverted
I want to go home
congratulations movie you gave saggy
boobs was this your goal to give shaggy
boobs what's that the whole reason for
this film existing the only time the
words Shaggy and boobs should go
together is in a British porno and even
though with a restraining order I guess
Raja Gosnell Oh what he's tears now
stupid and now he's a genius oh I long
for the blissful ignorance of my former
self taking hats
command rear end eating my own vomit oh
those were wonderful times I think we
just saw Casa Nell working through some
personal stuff there the rest of the
gang meets up and they see where the
costumes are brought to life ah the
poster to the thing Zika I needed that I
needed that too you're pushing your luck
Scoob and I think that was Matthew
Lillard cracking on the movie just
imagine he's not talking about the dog
he's talking about the whole film you're
pushing your luck Scoob pretty credible
they run away from the rejected Zelda
henchman and tried to escape not
realizing that they've unleashed the
monsters and the city blames them
heather jasper-howe with an emergency
update reporting live from Zardoz a
monster army has invaded Coolsville
to be fair they do look more realistic
than the new Ghostbusters movie so they
go to their old clubhouse where they
used to be kids because nobody will look
for mystery ain't get a place called
mystery age and they remember when they
were all in high school a mere 20 years
ago
seemed so easy back then we saw
mysteries for the love of them not to
prove anything to anyone I think that is
the literal definition of solving a
mystery proving things to everyone no
what are you suck at what you do you
don't even know what you do but the
monsters find them and continue to chase
them down
luckily they give them the slip wait
that's not a baby huh guess it's better
than crashing into this billboard dude
they come across the Black Knight yet
again and even though DAF need to feed
him before and knows exactly how to take
him down flat decides to take him on
funny because that weapon would have
been very handy fighting the electricity
monster
well now you're both screwed because
Fred needed to make his dick feel a
little bigger lovely okay
guess this is it huh no this is laying
on the ground for a few seconds while
the monsters are far far away from you
there's nothing this is it about that at
all
Scooby and Shaggy come across the pirate
ghosts who breathe fire but it's okay
because could be farts and your kid has
eaten his own brain congratulations your
red box rental has taken a life you
could have been watching Doris enchanted
forest adventures dude you gotta been
watching cars intended for adventure but
once again they try to make it look like
someone else is the bad guy but that
gets resolved when he sees Velma's life
thank God she has a shadowy skirt you
gotta trust me I only trust the facts
but all the facts say that you're the
evil masked figure what is your heart
saying then I have a better career with
Disney than Warner Brothers at this
point she said that the gang has to face
the real mastermind and the monsters in
a final battle
I found out that would freeze oil this
movie about a talking dog has finally
jumped the shark for me he is allowed to
give I guess I'll badass lie who do you
think you huh Scooby Dobby no mutter
mutter so the monsters are all destroyed
and it's finally revealed who the
mastermind is no shit lucky for her she
had an assistant helping her along with
her evil plans
Ned whoa who is Ned Oh
the cameraman you almost never saw was
mentioned once if even that way to drop
those seeds of knowledge movie oh wait
there's even more
oh wait who's that the pterodactyl guy
who never got a line and they said was
dead earlier Wow not only is that a
horribly put together mystery but you
clearly don't know how to use your Tim
Blake Nelson we're it dude this whole
time applause dummkopf okay maybe you
know a little bit but we cuddled I
touched your shaggy boobs
but wait just when you think it's over
they have a marble style and credit
sequence
hey boy veins secret go even your own
credit sequence sucks if you really
wanted to do this right you have Samuel
Jackson in an eyepatch go up to James
Gunn and say I'm here to talk about a
proposition because this is horrible and
that's for the worst thing about it Oh
Gus
Lexi Jules get in here I see you haven't
found the mastermind who gave you the
movie yet even though it's pretty
frigging obvious it's almost like that
movie Roger Rabbit or the location of
the Jolly Roger because someone is
obviously rogering you Roger Roger Roger
Roger Roger breakfasty Roger Roger Roger
that's all I have to say please don't be
stupid
hi any news
as a matter of fact there is officer we
know who is behind this ordeal and that
of course is Jules sorry it had to be
this way my love
let's end this by satirizing something
that ties into the show's theme let's
tap into the zany mysterious antics of
class act
no goddamnit
no you did everything wrong everything
first you get the satire wrong then you
get the satire in the satire wrong and
you do these awful impressions of one of
us as long as Matic series I've got sex
you're dead Carrie wasn't even white are
you indicating that there's a shortage
of white actors in media then you try to
solve this bullshit mystery that's so
frigging obvious and you'll still get it
wrong Jay's not the one who did it was
me Roger
it was Roger all along Roger Roger Roger
Roger Roger Roger hi Roger Roger yeah we
know it was you Roger but she's still
the one who did what yeah I'm definitely
guilty but he can't be I did him ahh you
only think that you did you see I know
that you laid the DVD there for me but
when I looked away it was replaced by a
slightly different version the original
I then noticed was snuck into Jules's
pocket my second clue was a ton that
fell on me I'm sure you tried to drop it
first but Jules cut the rope before you
did as I noticed her rope cutting
scissors she tried kicking under the
couch and finally when you said write
down the name of the culprit she didn't
write Roger
she wrote Jules
but what was the point of all this
because I want to give something that
the movie didn't a good mystery
sure scooby-doo as a show is silly and
not the best animated but one thing it
always had was a good mystery for kids
it taught them deductive reasoning
problem-solving skills it was a show
that made them smarter in every episode
that was the movie's ultimate failure
sure the sets were nice and there was an
occasional funny scene the actors could
pull off but the effects were awful the
jokes fell flat and a multi-million
dollar movie couldn't tell a better
mystery than every episode of the
shoestring budget cartoon that's what
makes it last through all these
incarnations not just the silly
characters but the fact that it's making
you more observant without even knowing
it as the best kind of teaching should
be so I figure do what the movie was
trying to do tell a fake-out mystery
that actually faked you out okay well
now that that's out there it's time to
explain why I did this and how I came
back neither scooby-doo nor a sight
cared about the motivation yeah it's
there but it's more of a side note but
it's so complex and interesting I don't
know short and shallow is usually the
way to go yes and I would have gotten
away with it too if it weren't for you
pesky kids and that mangy dog
scooby-dooby-doo
you
we know baby
coming next week it's how true was on
the dais everybody says it's bullshit
but how right are they but you can see
it now under vessels ad free early
access just three dollars a month to see
tons of people's videos early as well as
a bunch of other extra features check it
out and get the early scoop hey Doug
Walker here doing the charity shout out
this week we are doing donate life net
this is a not-for-profit alliance of
national organizations and state teams
across the u.s. committed to increasing
the numbers of donated organs over 121
thousand people are waiting for an organ
and every 10 minutes another person is
added to the list and sadly so many of
those people pass away before they're
able to get the organs it's honestly a
much bigger problem than a lot of us
probably assumed this is an organization
that not only helps those people but
also encourages others to donate they
develop and execute effective multimedia
donor education programs motivate the
American public to register now as an
organ donor and assist donate life state
teams and national partners in
facilitating high performing donor
registries in its 23 years of existence
the donate life community has grown
donor designation to nearly 129 million
registered and that's in the United
States alone that's an amazing number
but we still need more so check out
their website look at their YouTube
videos become an organ donor if you're
not already and see how many various
ways you can help out definitely click
on the link and check them out
you